JeJe mettais les deux plates-
foformes à côôtété, on peut débe
lolongtemps, ça se ressemble. Iy
a a des nuances. Dans laissnte,
DeDenis Coderre veut développern
anancien golf. Commentaire
gégénéral, sur cette plate-forme
dede madame Plante?
- - J'ai mêmeme écouté la confée
dede presse. Je l'ai réécouté dx
fofois pour bien comprendre. 250
prpromesses. J'ai arrêtété de ls
cocompter, d'arrêteter de compte
bubudget, j'étais rentré à 4,8,8
mimilliards de promesses. Le
bubudget de la ville, ces 6,2
mimilliards. J'espèrere qu'on aa
unun panel sur le budget
évéventutuellement le 6 novembr.
C'C'est dans un mois jour pour
jojour. Il y a beaucoup de
prpromesses. Est-ce qu'elles
seseront irréalisables? Je ne ss
papas. Là ouù j'ai un doute, sua
hahausse des taxes. Elle a proms
vivigoureusement de ne pas les
auaugmenter. 2007, elle avait
prpromis vigoureusement de ne ps
leles augmenter. Elle les a
auaugmentés quand mêmeme. Elle t
prpromis d'abolir la taxe de
bibienvenue. Elle est restée et
elelle est augmentée aussi. Je
susuis sceptique aujourd'hui.
C'C'est ma journée scepticisme.
EnEn fait coupé dans d'autres
seservices pour pouvoir réaliser
seses promesses.
- - Luc?
- - C'est axé sur les quartiers.
C'C'est le cas un projet Montrél
ququi voulait des grands projets
etet voulait 37 km de tramway, e
dedensification au centre-ville.
DeDepuis son départ, projet
MoMontréal s'est beaucoup oriené
vevers la vie de quatre de la
popossibilité de tout trouvait
dadans son quartier, d'avoir des
éqéquipements, des
ininfrastructures, des commerces
prproches. Et beaucoup de
veverdissement. Cette plate-fore
plpleinement sa vision.
- - Qu'est-ce qui est l'élément
nonouveau qui devrait faire la
nonouvelle selon vous là-dededa?
LeLes caméras sur les policiers,
leles deux vaccins, les terrasss
chchauffées, les deux ça, zone
zozone zéro émission, l ça se
reressent beaucoup.
QuQu'est-ce qui différencie seln
vovous et qu'est-ce qui la
didifférencie de Denis Coderre?
LeLes deux disent la mêmeme cho.
PoPour M. Coderre, c'est nouveau
dede parler de logement. On est
trtrès loloin de ça. Pour Mme
PlPlante, c'est nouveau de parlr
dede sécurité. Il y a un chassé-
crcroisé.
LeLe logement, Mme Plante y a
totoujours tenu énormément.
ImImpossible de régler la solutn
àà couourt terme.
IlIl va falloir que Québec
s's'implique beaucoup plus danse
lologement si on veut des
sosolutions.
- - Sur le logement, vous avez é
lala dernièrere fois il y a deuu
trtrois panels avait été assez
crcritique.
- - Oui. C'est permis de rêverr
sasans qu'il faut livrer la
mamarchandise. Sur le nombre de
lologement social il y en a 1042
susur les simulations des
prpremiers. Et en plus
auaujourd'hui, ce qui m'a aussi
fafait réfléchir, c'est la
ququestion...
onon a posé la question :
ququi est responsable du logeme?
LaLa réponse que Mme Plante a dt
totoutut à faiait sur le fly :
vovous savez le logement c'est a
reresponsabilité du gouvernement
féfédéral et provivincial. On eà
popour appuyer et cogner aux
poportes. Déjà en n partant moie
m'm'aperçois que si on ne réalie
papas ce n'est pas de ma faute.
C'C'ététait que Québec et Ottawe
nonous a pas donné les sous.
J'J'aimerais bien que les citoys
aiait un portrait clair de ce
ququ'on promet. On donne des
prpromesses qu'on ne peut pas
réréaliser.
JeJe parle des deux côtétés. Je
m'm'assume dans ce que je dis. l
fafautut que les citoyens
cocomprennent que lorsqu'on leur
prpromet des choses, ça ne veut
papas dire que ça va se faire.
C'C'est ça qui est dommageable
acactuellement.
- - Très bibien. En tout cas les
prpriorités, vous êtetes d'acco,
sosont pas les mêmemes.
- - Ça commence à r ressembler.
- - On n'en revient aux qualités
dede leader.
QuQuelle est la différence de
leleadership?
JeJe vous amènene à l la campage
CoCoderre.
IlIl a parlé à b beaucoup de ge,
d'd'ailleurs, il vous a parlé
AnAnnie.
IlIl a parlé à vous.s.
IlIl a parlé à b beaucoup de ge.
LaLa campagne de Monsieur Codere
esest difficile. Il a perdu des
plplumes dans les sondages. Je
vovous fais entendre un exemple
ququi illustre le mieux cela.
C'C'est la statue de John A.
MaMacdonald.
- - Il devrait revenir..
paparce qu'on ne déboulonnera ps
lala passé, mais on devrait avor
dedes plaques explicatives.
L Le problèmeme, ce n'est peute
papas la statue, mais c'est
lele piédestal qui vient avec.
JeJe pense qu'on devrait changer
lala "Place du Canada" en
lala "Place de la réconciliatio.
- - Le premier principe
dede la réconciliation, c'est
dede cesser de décider pour
leles Autochtones ce qui est bon
popour eux. Je trouve ca malaist
quque M. Coderre décide sans mêe
paparler à p personne ce qui dot
êêtrtre fait. Je pense que ça
dédémontre un paternalisme dont
leles Autochtones veulent vraimt
sese débarrasser. Ils en ont
asassez de ça.
CeCe sont de bons exemples.
MoMonsieur Godard dit qu'il a ps
unune décision. Il a le droit de
didire sa décision. Il a le drot
dede dire que cela devrait rever
avavec une plaque de
cocontractualisation. Deux jours
apaprès,s, il dit qu'il n'est ps
ssûr.r. Mme Plante elle dit qu'l
fafaut consulter. Il faut
coconsulter il faut parler. Je e
sasais pas si la statue va rever
ouou pas. Je ne sais pas quelle
dédécision sera prise. Qu'est-ce
quque ça vous dit sur la campage
dede M. Coderre et la campagne e
MmMme Plante.
- - Monsieur Coderre a le pied r
l'l'accélérateur. Ce que je
reretiens c'est que Monsieur
CoCoderre a agi beaucoup avec ls
émémotions. C'est un gars qui ae
l'l'intuition méga beaucoup
d'd'émotions et actuellement la
raraison est supposée prendre la
plplace et ses émotions ont paré
trtrop rapidement encore et de
l'l'autre côté M Mme Plante quie
veveut pas trop faire... ne pas
trtropop déranger « ces bobos st
rarassurants en disant qu'on ne
pepeut pas dire quoi faire.
OnOn un dialogue. Beaucoup plus
poposé. Dany là-desessus a été
bebeaucoup plus....
- - il a dû receculer parce ques
ddîtetes qu'il y a eu de la
tetentation d'aller trop loin. l
nene sait pas assumer.
- - C'est un nouveau domaine
lele déboulonnage de statut. Ona
totoujours recommandé de ne pas
fafaire cela impunément.
C'C'est la position qu'avait
adadoptée. C'est en train de
chchanger. L'université de Migul
àà enlnlever la statue
dede James McGill
ququi est pourtant le fondateure
l'l'université.
MoMonsieur Coderre n'est peut-êe
papas au fait que cela a changé.
IlIl n'est pas aussi critique
cecela. Il peut simplement diree
chchangement de nom, c'est une
proposition, on va l'étudier
avavec les communautés concernés
avavec l'ensemble des montréala.
FiFin de la discussion.
- - Ça ne montre pas aussi que s
popositions dans ses sujets
cocontroversésés, plus tranchéee
pepeuvent plus passer la rampe.l
nene pourrait plus dire moi je
crcrois qu'on ne peut pas
dédéboulonner l'histoire.
OnOn ne déboulonne pas les
ststatuts.
- - C'est difficile de le dire.
IlIl faut l'assumer aussi.
EfEffectivement, comme le clavi,
onon ne peut pas changer
l'l'histoire il faut la
cocomprendre. Il faut trouver le
momoment de l'expliquer
cocorrectement. Est-ce que Maîte
dedes pancartes auraient changé
ququelque chose? Je ne suis pas
coconvaincu. C'est un gros débat
dede société sur l'ensemble de e
ququi fêtetent parti de notre p.
- - Luc,
ququand vous avez des maires de
l'l'arrondissement,
vovous avez fait des choses que
leles gens n'aimaient pas.
- - Il faut faire des choses que
leles gens n'aiment pas mais il
fafaut le dire en campagne
élélectorale. Je ne peux pas
ararriver avec des changements
apaprès. J Je ne peux pas dire e
j'j'ai dépensé 15 millions là--
dedessus qui n'est pas du tout
dadans ma plate-forme. Si le
cacampagne électorale qui
s's'affiche comme ça, le prêt,tl
pepeut le faire. D'ailleurs un
mamaire, i il concentre énormémt
dede pouvoir. Ça va arriver
sosouvent qu'ils vont prendre ds
dédécisions rapides sans avoir
coconsulté tout le monde. Pas sr
dedes gros gros gros projet...
- - mais c'est la nature de note
sysystème..
MeMerci beaucoup à v vous deux.
OnOn va parler de Longueuil
etet de Laval...
j'j'ai trouvé ça intéressant
ququ'ils disent qu'ils veulent
paparler de logement. Ils veulet
fafaire équipe et il y a quelque
chchose de rafraîchisissant.
- - Ça fait du bien d'entendre .
SiSi les deux sont élus il va
ququand mêmeme y avoir un poids
imimportant dans la discussion
avavec la CNN.
JeJe trouve ça très s intéressa.
C'C'est très s bien s'il y avais
dodossiers comme cela qui sont
plplus souvent discutés entre
cecertains maires.
- - Wow! 29 et 33 ans. Il y a
totoute e une nouvelle solutionr
lele logement.
IlIls vont mettre de la pression
susur Québec.
LeLe changement de loi nécessaie
auaussi bravo bravo bravo.